-As you guys know, we're always
striving to get better here
at "The Tonight Show."
[ As Daft Punk ] ♪ Harder,
better, faster, stronger ♪
[ Laughter ]
Which is why we asked viewers
at home to send in
any suggestions that they have
just to get some feedback
about what you guys think
of the show,
things you'd like to see us do,
that kind of stuff.
So tonight, let's look inside
the audience suggestion box!
♪ Look into the box,
the suggestion box ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There we go.
This first one here is from
Rosemary Woods.
"Hey, Jimmy, I saw that
Lifetime Channel started airing
their new Christmas movies
this week,
even though it's not even
Halloween yet.
Maybe you could review some
on the show."
Gosh, I'd really like to,
but I just don't have the time
to watch Lifetime Christmas
movies right now.
Sorry.
-Jimmy,
what are you talking about?
There's always time
for Lifetime Christmas movies
no matter what time of year
it is.
-No, Tariq.
[ Sighs ] There isn't.
Between this show and the
election, and moving back
to my hometown to help
with my family's
struggling wreath farm...
[ Laughter ]
it's just not realistic. Okay?
-Wow.
I-I had no idea you were -- you
were under so much pressure.
-Yeah, well, I am.
[ Laughter ]
And to top it all off, I have to
plan the big holiday parade
that the whole town comes to
and I don't even have a theme
picked out yet.
-Well, Jimmy, the answer might
be closer than you think.
Look under your desk.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
It's a snow globe I made
when I was a kid.
[ Laughter ]
That's it, the --
the theme of the parade
should be "snow globes."
And my family can sell
our wreaths at the parade
to save the farm,
and then I'll have time
to watch Lifetime movies!
That fixes everything!
Thanks, Tariq.
Tariq?
[ Sleigh bells ringing ]
[ Laughter ]
You just saved Christmas, bud.
-Hello, Lifetime Channel? Yeah,
you can send that check now.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, let's get to
our next suggestion here.
This one's from Michelle Brown.
"Hey, Jimmy, I'm glad everyone
is staying safe
by canceling their Halloween
parties this year.
But I'm really going to miss
all the fun Halloween games.
Do you think you could give us
some Halloween fun
by bobbing for an apple?"
Uh, sure, I'd love to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
-Whoo!
An iPhone, cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
These are waterproof, right?
All right, let's get another
suggestion here.
This one doesn't have a name
on it.
But, anyway, it says, "Hey,
Jimmy, here's a suggestion --
suck it."
[ Bass playing ]
Hey, Ma-- Mark, did you do this?
-Yeah, that's right. Suck it!
[ Laughter ]
-No! You suck it!
[ Bass playing ]
-No, you suck it!
[ Laughter ]
-I hate you, Mark!
-I hate you, too, Jimmy!
-Next suggestion!
-Good!
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, Jimmy, I love Halloween.
I also love WWE.
Is there any way you can combine
the two?"
I can't, but I know who can.
And his name, The Undertaker.
Check it out.
[ Wolf howling ]
[ Insects chirping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell tolling ]
♪♪
-[ Growls ]
[ Grunts ]
[ Sighs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Rest...in...
peace.
[ Bell tolls ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our thanks to The Undertaker.
Undertaker's 30th anniversary
will be celebrated
at Survivor Series on Sunday,
November 22nd
streaming on WWE Network.
We love that guy.
Thanks again, Undertaker.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are down to our last
suggestion.
It is from Ramona Ostrowski.
"Hey, Jimmy, I loved
Black Simon & Garfunkel.
Can you have them on the show
again?"
Actually, it's so weird
you actually asked that
because last night, I was having
a socially distant dinner
over at Mendel's on the park,
and Black Simon & Garfunkel
showed up to sing a new version
of one their classic songs.
So, here to perform
"Scarborough Fair Online,"
give it up for
Black Simon & Garfunkel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Are you going to
Scarborough Fair? ♪
♪♪
♪ It got pushed,
and now it's online ♪
♪♪
♪ They're showing every spice
on Screen Share♪
♪♪
♪ I just chugged my fourth
glass of wine ♪
♪♪
♪ Are you going to
my cousin's bris? ♪
♪♪
♪ Why'd the hell
they move this online? ♪
♪♪
♪ They're live streaming
to my Oculus ♪
♪♪
♪ I hit HD at the worst time ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Give it up for
Black Simon & Garfunkel!
That is all the time we have
for "Audience Suggestion Box."